Worshipful podcast welcome to the water
food podcast
Felipe Esparza here always here oh the
realtor is over there Jimmy we have a
special guest tonight finesse Mitchell
right here yeah chillin oh we got our
jolly rookie right here man with his
perm yeah at least that right here
what's up what's up what you go take a
[ __ ]
no well for whatever reason I thought it
would that Wi-Fi password that should be
on my internet so I want to do Wi-Fi
cold it's like chicken nuggets I thought
it was got the city you're real we laugh
anybody would be at someone's house you
know and like give you in there already
for like an hour like okay man I think
about you're somebody's house from now
it's time to the people taking that
Wi-Fi password dude I got chewed 1 bar
or you were there for an hour and then
like you're like I love the [ __ ]
don't keep this house this hot when I'm
not around that I see something turn on
a fan we were Florida at least has our
ads house and man not only was it hot
she was smoking it was hot for like Toby
rule we don't wait know how because
black people involved we as soon as we
walk in your house
we want the code and a charger because
I've found guys like 6 percent left and
we don't even really know who house we
yet we could just be a friend of a
friend
like yo man you got to charge it and we
show what you got Wi-Fi ah you're gonna
laugh I do who are you so yeah that's
real I don't like when people like show
up to your house and immediately they
want to hear the rest of what I do you
dig a station or start by the way here
weed that cool dog [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
in my house start buzzing away you're
nice man I could show you what you have
ways that's a freeway stop oh yeah it's
always two dudes with the curly perms
that gotta take a [ __ ] far as like
public restrooms the best ones are
Starbucks man they always have paper
everything you go to like Arco station
man they hand you that key to a rim
connected to a car and possibly that leg
from the Christmas or if you're in a big
city the best one to use the public
library unless you go to Seattle to
Bellevue Bellevue no was it Spokane
Washington
oh my god some heroin addict wouldn't in
there too the [ __ ] like right before us
it's not like death dogs we see the walk
out of there - oh I like a tree growing
I work at Starbucks cuz I ain't givin
nobody - Cole the real code the real car
you gotta buy at least 20 bucks of stuff
if you want to use my bathroom at a
Starbucks I know I'll be on the news
immediately because I'd be
discriminating against everybody
Byron Bauer without a Starbucks and
there was a white dude chillin and that
fool had a computer a word processor and
a printer bro yes well people use the
star boys their office huh oh yeah yeah
you know they abuse it it's like dude
come on man I know that overhead dude
cutting it down but this is ridiculous
though you have a business running that
[ __ ] out of Starbucks you
I had you the restaurant or somebody
house and their house was dirty brawling
on the way here like the labor room and
then a bathroom have water and a floor
and I actually wanted a floor and the
[ __ ] floor patent of the [ __ ] town
is chipping as he would grab my toilet
paper is gonna fall off a piece of tile
hood upon my head something dude Oh most
of the time the toilet not and loose oh
man can't [ __ ] with no toilet loose bro
picture my ass I know somebody who a
toilet broke on their ass and they cut
their ass crazy I knew a guy that I was
in a band [ __ ] that guy he fell on a
drum stool the seat fell off he went
down on the pole had to have surgery
major surgery on his colon it was
horrible he did that at like 17 years
old 16 17 but yeah dude we got gas dog
Chicago what's up fool Master Zhu what
happened to us bad foot well do and I
went to do a show and Dallas mm-hmm and
we get this with that where we live
earlier I was delayed going there too
right so we got there at 1:30 in the
morning and went to get up for press and
what 6:30 hmm and the next day or the
next day our flight was delayed for
hours and then we got and we were lose
have [ __ ] a weirdo get a rental car
we're across the street from the rental
car place and Toby Hayes was drinking at
the bar watching football games and he
hooks up with Mary Lou Retton for real a
little tricky partner no not jump on
bears or something
look at pebbles Carlos hey guys come
back we're leaving in five minutes
so we have to rush back to TSA and it
was the same TSA we saw in the morning
yeah they're good at but those are good
actors because they never seem to thaw
day at the same stuff that we went
through the first time what happens when
I fight skied elated people to know
about the free sandwiches the free chips
and the free snacks from on the flight
delay they bring up this car full of
sandwiches having cheese turkey and
cheese veggie wraps ribs sodas orange
juice cookies and as soon as I see that
I start following a guy and they never
say oh come grab these sandwiches just
stop take off go yell at your ass just
take two bites on the sandwich throw it
away sample King he he took my son
around to to get samples in the mall in
the food and there was one place that
had a wing they would give you a fat
chicken wing and some whatever flavor
you wanted right wing yeah it's like
this Chinese place with wings and then
one time they didn't have any wings they
they told Isaac to come back come back
fifteen minutes we'll have some more
Tyler
it was like six years old seven years
old we went to doesn't understeer just
Brown we gotta go we gotta go mom like
it's been 15 minutes so we goes oh sorry
we're late
I need to get that sample
they don't do samples like Asians too
especially at the grocery stores whole
back day they used to always had a
little toothpick tray Costco yeah oh
they have a lady there cookie yeah
[Music]
always bought the links people remember
that people remember going and getting
in that line three three times a you
ever pick up just like four toothpicks
and the person just look at you like is
there food you giving it away
[Laughter]
excuse me sir just one will cheese with
pizza like pizza grilled cheeses and man
I was just talking to her brush you know
watch about Lurky bro like why are you
gonna mark that's a four bro and she
looked at me like open up that box lady
Jamie Lee Curtis she back in full effect
my heart is broken I still oh she's
still
Norman Bates over here
mojo 6 so that flight sandwiches got
psyched out those Mexicans going to
another to Puebla but they play without
the latest I wish you wish there are
scare project or winner I think I bunch
of sodas that I saw that wasn't you a
free brother more focused often take
damage
what about Toby Higgs that food speaking
early I guess you you're drinking you
know when you expect a flight to leave
you start drinking if you're not howling
or you like to party please drinking is
drinking and then I'm talking to the guy
man so when you telling me that we're
gonna end up getting stuck here and it
told me on the other side I'll drug boy
can you guarantee we're gonna make it we
got a show out there you stood a white
girl cuz you know he went oh girl you
know and she was driving like four hours
to meet him there from for another town
where we got delayed so one so like
there now we got four hours he was
looking at your ticket says today
teittleman he we get the red turns out
we get in the car and I told you just
put
she his jacket over here can't take the
bow man we're driving two hours in
waiting shitty ass town we never heard
like Buffalo New York t no Buffalo
buffalo Texas a gue but when we get to
Buffalo man and it came down we were
like it was like light and then [ __ ]
pitch black I never seen [ __ ] no
darkness right then everybody's phone
when I was a state that boo boo boo - I
don't know - they don't know tornado
alert
oh yeah turn around we're the only car
in a freeway so [ __ ] this man y'all
gonna keep going is the worst damn so we
see is she waiting in the car and this
[ __ ] that's potato to the right of us
hell no [ __ ] pulled out of Dallas
Brian tell these fools because I don't
want it to be all panicky far away it
was within seeing distance we call the
road manager somebody hired to work only
it's work sort of dates with Craig go to
Walmart bro
I'm a pair of pants pair of socks and
underwear I swear to God my job was it
to the down at that a pair pair of pants
a pair of socks and underwear cuz you
only brought one underwear who sounds
one underwear
the underworld I never wear man target
employees make you look like a dad that
Syracuse storm that we drove
Entertainment him but now you leave a
suit accuse the day before taste give it
to make it home and we were the only car
and that black dudes like play music Tom
your eyes to his DJ right it wasn't bro
it was first of all everybody who came
to the show that night was like yeah we
leavin tonight cuz it's a star and now
dumbasses oh yeah storm coming
cool cool but we it wasn't registering
yeah home was coming and sure enough man
we woke up that morning I am winter
wonderland it was a blizzard hit and the
dude who was taking us to the airport
which was about an hour and a half away
yeah cuz we was leaving we want to
Syracuse you guys had all those long
like military bases were like an hour
out from the airport four or five in the
morning or something to get there right
it was like it was crazy bro it was like
dude was doing 50 miles per hour to like
60 which felt like 120 on black ice on
black ice and he kept saying ah nah man
I know the weather dog like when you can
see the white line still in the street
that mean check out my son demo what
ya'll entertainment right yeah literally
only car manic on the road you know you
know the movie the beginning of Fargo
the cop car the white snow us and then
we pull loads to the side just to see
like wait out yeah then we saw one of
those snow plows yeah
that was God the first one that was God
the only worse we got behind a
[ __ ] I was in a snow plow cuz
they got to the point well I look I look
back at Felipe I was like if you ain't
gonna say something but that he wanted
me to want to say something right but
you have to say so but you got to say
sounds like your life even if you feel
like you can do this
it ain't that important I missed that
flight just pull over let's figure this
out we never should have left the hotel
like all this emotion start coming out
you know I was like look man let's just
figure this out and we look to the left
[ __ ] snowplow who's just coming down
the road never I'll agree tag blessed
[Music]
I'm too far to go back too far to go
back and so it's like [ __ ] these clothes
now but that one brother was casual
though driving dude he was casual bro
that [ __ ] was on his phone
driving with his knees he was trying to
find a CB are you CD he still had a book
of CDs yeah he was gonna did miss
another show I put up together when we
got to the airport he almost killed me
oh that's [ __ ] edible the start the
start of debutant do and before they
have it before they took the potency out
and there stood over the Joe Diaz once I
gave him one and one hour later that
fool like God I want to do the left I'm
running crying thesis how I got the tear
come down this cheek and went up my face
the other side that was a beer mama
blood oh here's the crazy thing
so I'm trying to pride myself on like oh
yeah man you know I don't want to go to
where there's no girl yeah yeah
[Applause]
but we in the airport and we Sydney are
we happy that we made it he gave me the
edible I'm looking at and he was like
you take this get on the flight you're
gonna sleep the whole weight out of the
duct I was like all right cool
and whatnot big but it was the saddest
one of them little caramel chunks that
you get on Halloween yeah I was like all
right [ __ ] it take it take it and I'm
looking at me like yes oh you know I
tell you what fool my flight this way
great working with you see you next time
my man see you next time so he walked
off and I go to my gate I sit there and
all of a sudden my heart why why do I
hear no yeah so then I see him walking
back but this time I'm all jittery and I
try to control myself so I grab stuff
I'm grabbing my suitcase I'm grabbing
everything you don't want to fall
because you know this Emma want me so
I'm sitting there trying to play it cool
and then he's like oh by the way fool
just want to say next week is this and
then you know let's hook up and out of
the diner done but I'm out and I'm like
okay he walks off I [ __ ] you not
my hand does this and this stuck there
you're gonna wave so now I'm like holy
[ __ ] I can't get on the plane I make it
up I stand up I start walking real slow
over to this bar I just wanted some
water if I could get and people walking
at me and just looking like this so I
look like this through I look like
through at this point and I'm telling
myself [ __ ] finesse don't get on his
plane if you get on his plane
I'll freak the [ __ ] out they're going to
land the plane you and I just said
please let this go away thanks drama
finesse I felt like if we was in the
hotel he gave me the Bill Cosby edible
like a baby [ __ ]
that was like I'm about to pass out any
goddamn second and I ain't gonna
remember what happened you're gonna roll
with it ran through real quick and I
remember I think we put them in an
Instagram story but an hour later I
don't know what they gave me man go
through like three or four of those
instances to be able to realize that it
nothing's gonna happen cuz you have to
do it because that's happening right and
dude like but after you get that [ __ ]
Ben you're cool cuz you know see one
time I was on the plane man [ __ ] I
was like listening to the inaudible on a
plane that works for me water and just
[ __ ] loud music he took the same one
and you know how how you're getting a
you know like a a 27 on Southwest mm-hmm
this was sad who like see 40 I want you
to know that I'll be last the thing is
when you are if you're not used to
edibles like dude hit you with the
paranoia [ __ ] you know that's what you
can shake and go south if you used to it
mmm-hmm cuz those [ __ ] are
potent dog yeah I had when I made those
I used to make the what did they call it
fruity pebbles pebbles she's like rice
krispies treats but no pebbles and
infused butter right and and I'm eight
one one time and I couldn't get off my
couch and I felt like I was going
through PMS I was having hot flashes and
like feeling nauseous
I should stop for me and that's too much
for me I cannot handle it I have a go
crawl to take a [ __ ] looking for a
sweater and just like you just very hard
to get on your feet
I was walking slow as [ __ ] man I was
like I could hear everything I could
feel everything everything was an
out-of-body experience but I felt like
my heart was about to pop yeah
[Music]
Here I am took the weed brownies
brownies I think I think we're dead
I think we're dead like he really thinks
yeah those brownies and that was off of
like what mid great mid grease we the
oil and everything right in that [ __ ] up
so finessing that we were like an army
base tour brochure or what to tells I
would never go to now it's like a price
woman who said yeah I did an interview
today where it lady was like I just want
to thank you for what you do for the
military like you always go out of your
way to do shows for the military I'm you
know I'm currently still in the military
I was like yeah and I always say Felipe
Esparza tried to kill me I always bring
up the story but when I think about it
yeah man I do a lot of military shows I
don't know
so shout out to the military I guess it
checks clear do we will get to these
military bases and every time we got
there I think God down we should just
eat before even [ __ ] God he loves
you're gonna starve yeah yeah and every
military base shoutout to everybody in
the military but every military base got
their own mayor got they own know that
all that yeah their runs everything that
runs everything he's the mayor of that
base you know what I mean he's like the
for everybody that's coming on that's
like a guest like you gonna meet that
guy you got introduced he introduced you
all the captains all to God and they and
it was so funny I always say uh you know
because it was me
seaton and Felipe so that would be like
hey welcome to the base is gonna be a
great show and they look at Felipe and
they'd be like so yeah you know we can't
do drugs we gotta watch what we say on
the show it can't just be over the top
and then they look back at me and then
they be like and we can't talk about
Trump or somebody a give a complex or
something yeah he thought they were to
beat my ass no I don't know I did you
know Philippe I did this thing you know
I was a DJ and I miss at the bottom okay
I was but you DJ male motive everybody
that was high class at this base was
doing something that high class no more
like this guys they're not ranking this
before yeah man I should I shot these I
shot that well what do you shoot I'm a
photographer we'd always shot Dave I
Poconos Philippe lot left out a huge
chunk of this story why he didn't know
like Philippe and that's why I'm not on
the What's Up boo podcast to let the
fill in the blanks are you ready for
this one this was a doozy are you ready
for this this is a doozy
you remember so many things I remember
once he tried to kill me with the edible
I said I gotta stay on my toes and just
remember everything and document
everything this is the power Philippe is
leaving out the dew had vitiligo don't
believe me get up his first joke was he
and shout-out to the DJ who got his own
camouflage on a military base he miss to
say I was this I was that you know he to
DJ he tryin to get our music but he said
all the other study was I know I didn't
[Applause]
see as a crowd they would have laughed
it out would be cleaner oh and we met
this guy that that the would be the
military's for a long time historia yeah
man it was one girl like what the
comedian took her from me oh my god
swooped on her man grant Williams took
his lady
oh man we had an uber driver live
forever and [ __ ] out Dallas and she
had dude she had a one of those milk
carts and she [ __ ] tips like a milk
jug
oh this window over yeah a big-ass milk
jug I was telling this story about
telling brothers with a little person oh
man you know how for sometime just me to
my destination little driver he'll tell
you his crazy okay
this driver will tell his crazy is fair
no matter what he'll tell you so he's
not like you know make it short talk he
didn't want he didn't want anything to
do them but then we just started
clicking start talking yeah man this was
go so sir which is your craziest dried
dog last night I had a [ __ ] try to
choke me yeah sit on the back seven yeah
he picked up a [ __ ] at a bar that was
drunk that got kicked out of a bar
they'd said by the way so then homeboy
saw picks him up he's all drunk I need
the [ __ ] was drunk and then he's all
let's go to let's go to breakfast he's
are now I can't go to breakfast I have
to have breakfast with my wife okay so
there's a little [ __ ] gets off the
seat and he's all he was pissed because
his legs would have bend over the seat
chunky style so then he stands up on the
ground and he goes behind the seat and
starts trying to strangle him I choke
him so homeboy pulls the car aboard
relax this and that should open a
certain manner [ __ ] I would have been
over a dude so me that was crazy so get
over the camouflage
that one hurt vitiligo it was forever
laughs it's funny but her will have a
complexion of a leopard I'm doing the
bunny and I feel bad what's your crazy
story my crazy bird driver I'm in
Cleveland and I leave I left the
Horseshoe Casino and this do I get in
and immediately as soon as I get in he
said finesse I said yeah he said I don't
and the music was blasted so I wanted to
make a phone call so I was like yo doc
you turn that down little bit like it's
like that oh yeah man I just you know I
just wanted I want to make a phone call
he's got you turned down a little bit
he's like yeah okay music I mean now
he's telling me that tonight in right he
was playing he's a demo right so I'm on
the phone and I'm having a conversation
he gets some phone this is a sour
looking for and so now I'm number
stations having our conversation when I
hear him say yeah man I'm still in my
conversation and then and then I hear ya
[ __ ] told me turn my muse down like
what the [ __ ] man
I'm just edible choke this guy and I'm
looking at the road I'm letting him know
I'm not on the phone oh boy
and so then he's like yeah man so uh let
me call you back cuz now now homie
staring at me
do I say something like I'm by myself
I'm in Cleveland put the [ __ ] do I do I
said [ __ ] did somebody say something and
he's in control the car yeah I said yo
excuse me he's like oh let me turn the
radio completely off he tried to cut me
up I yo you want me to turn the radio
completely up I said no man I mean you
talk about me like I got the right to
say turn the music down if I'm paying
for the ride I mean you should be
professional enough to just know that
you know or to just go with the tempo of
the passenger yeah it's not your car
once you're at work it's the person
paying for that time he was a year that
makes sense yes like I was saying
lecturing me and mom he makes his own
work environment uncomfortable for
himself this was the kicker he said you
don't stress he gets off the phone we
driving
he's like I'm lucky this [ __ ] around the
corner dawg you know it's true hang on
LA bro you don't stress me the [ __ ] out
he likes the blunt Oh
normally I would have been like you know
what I mean because it was late but if I
have to break bread yeah you know the
fact that I was already Pistons like
this the most unprofessional
uber [ __ ] ever the fact that he
little blunt in the car I was like yo
I'm about to give you a one-star while
I'm riding in I'm about to like send a
note right now and he was like do what
you got to do man and then he pulls over
and I'm like yeah it's right up there he
was like mom you gonna do that one star
[ __ ] just gonna get out I got out I had
to walk the last two blocks that was
Cleveland I thought you were gonna hit
that blood of your story hit that with
that blood no bad blood with dim blood
weak-ass blunt it was a rude
disrespectful
nobody has [ __ ] blunt one little skill
hurts him fool
first up my hangovers kill husband he's
hanging around with another type
[ __ ] named Juan Garcia his
cousin Juan Garcia chapel and well
Garcia notorious cheap bro I'm thinking
a guy do that you even if you were here
with you with your opener uh-huh your
biomarkers I shared your pirates flight
whatever but then you didn't have your
wallet you go get me a coffee
I'll get you a coffee that money you
make it with you both copies but so I'm
hanging around with skills and then like
skill skills um lights of blood and
she's there and then I'm the other for
Liza blood so [ __ ] life skills
smoking that [ __ ] I passed her Lisa and
then I'm she's gonna pass it back to
Warren and he said now [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
and then he lights up his bloody had
their own so I was then I share their
own blunts they're not sharing their
blood blood could what is cheap
I was surprised both of those blunts
equal half of blood there's no cheap
wine and wine oh just jump into the
circle if you don't know nobody you're
making a get in that blood and if you're
five bucks out and say like you want to
pay for yeah he would appear here five
hits yeah the doctors are done like
there's a little Roach and I get that
little Roach I'm gonna tear to the
Icehouse
so I thought in two days yeah I'm a
savior spoken with Bob Fisher blood oh
you were oh he was taking him on the
road for a while yes yes give this to
homie what up skills how do you beat
that poor girl he's either a lean either
right yeah I was uh
I was at the comedy union down on Pico
shut out the ends Mitchell running the
game so that's that's the og and uh
skills was up there doing this thing and
I think this is my first time watching
them and uh you know he pulled that hat
off in the middle of that drug yeah
and that [ __ ] I did not know about the
head put their hat on at the TSA broader
cultural - I mean that his skills go
literally from like 27 to light look
like the dad from goodtime 58 yeah when
he came on stage I went up to him and I
said was it home didn't even have a
suitcase at the time he had a suitcase
but it wasn't Beverly Hillbillies white
car wheels a Florida named Adam Murray
and they're in Orlando and as you know
buddy kind of like feel for people like
okay this was a big hard to get
advantage of I'll come up he goes to buy
an eighth before before the press
lecture I'd like it impressed me like
he's you know buy some weed we're gonna
smoke out before the radio he goes out
there man and comes back with a gram mmm
almost like a gram and says I got hosed
like pretty much think I went in there I
got robbed I gave her safety list all
she gave me I said man [ __ ] that let's
go so I invited him to go work with us
this with no luggage bro he's traveling
with uh like a hamper laundry yeah and
ER wet because he didn't have to go to a
dryer go to start a Florida you from
Florida what you're calling from Miami
me lift football there right play
the University of Miami shout-out to the
you scholarship but that was enough
financial aid to make it all worth it
you know that's good we won a
championship in 91 here in a
championship yeah wasn't the football
team Miami still the dopest college even
though story is true we were in Miami
are you probably know the guy from Miami
that the guy they travel to radio the
top or a Rican guy yeah he was telling
in the bathtub row right here in Florida
they don't play back in the days the
[ __ ] the Turner Laura high school -
there was a boat full of hookers wrong
yeah the Alumni will give this fool like
a big envelope with cash mm-hmm and then
whatever dope he was and then all the
hookers in a boat well I have I cannot
say they treat some crazy stories you
walk on the team or yeah absolutely
walked on you good for you man
what receiver was an audition but yeah
cornerback strong saftey and I played
two years I got kicked off the team
because of grades I had like a 1.5 GPA
daddy in football party friend Fred
cap alpha Sasha shout-out to all the
noobs out there the noobs kappa kappa
kappa yes so I did I did a lot of
Twitter
I did all that man and it was for me it
was just about I guess partying in
football practice and I never really
went to class and when I went it was
just to go you know but I was never
really taken no
and so uh when I was about to get kicked
out of school that's when I got serious
but I had to quit the team well I got
kicked off the team because you got to
be at least half a 2.0 or 2.3 or
something I didn't have it so they
kicked me off the team but I did
graduate I think I graduated like a 2.8
or 2.9 so I put like a 1.5 all the way
up to a 2.90
I'm working in South Florida and I'm
going to comedy shows and I'm talking
[ __ ] like one day I'm gonna do that one
day
so all the committee oh yeah comedians
come down and I was that dude that go
off to the side when when they come hey
Mike helps man I love your comedy man
one day know yeah hey Craig Robinson man
one day man I'm JB Smoove man my name
finesse Mitchell man what's up what's up
let me tell you something if you really
want to do come if you wanted to stand
the challenge this is what you got to do
you got to get on stage you got to stop
talking about god dude so I was like
alright man so next thing I know I start
going to open mic nights my first open
in Miami yep Coconut Grove Miami all
that original my originals over the
green rubber stage yeah Marvin Dixon no
no Marvin Dixon hood Angie Brown before
you he's been around
okay look it was on Def Jam yeah - yeah
I think I deal one I'm not sure he
backed down and shot the Cowgirls little
homie and uh but I got up there I got up
there I did an open mic night and I got
it bro I got a standing ovation I still
remember we only get three minutes yeah
that's about how how boys are kids how
we discover masturbation
like how we get in the shower at like 11
or 12 and all of a sudden you hard for
no reason and you don't figure out you
gotta figure out what yeah you don't
mean that was the whole thing it was it
was but it was genius the way I set it
up I painted this picture
I said finesse Mitchell that's my time
really I invited everybody to do was
like so this what really got me the host
was like yo dude that was really good
man so you never done comedy before I
said no he said you gotta come back next
week I said okay he's a come back okay
I'm buddy
everybody every but I wore a certain
time I invited all my friends I got up
there I didn't know you were supposed to
do the same exact routine I just thought
you'd get up there and start talking
nobody
it was so bad nobody cared the worst now
people think booing is the worst sound
silence nobody even you say a joke in
and nobody say nothing the old lady's
house I heard something worse than that
cuz it was like you know with black
folks I heard this that [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] - it's like a gun went off I
started joking at the end some chickens
I walked off stage when the show was
over everybody who I invited nobody came
up to me everybody kind of liked it that
way like we got to go like a man that's
one of your bits of advice that's one of
your top things that you devise people
who ask you advice for comedy you say
don't invite any of your family or
friends what you get better and those
body wants to watch a friend get better
anything good friends with stars am i
growing pain years anytime i was
horrible my friends to this day would
say remember that
[Laughter]
no matter what you're doing now Saturday
Night Live movie I got my one hour
special dropping this Friday Showtime
the spirit told me to tell you I still
get somebody tell me hey man move that
time to Miami improv and that girl sit
[Laughter]
and I'll never forget it because this is
what made me hungry
made me say I'll be back next man
because I remembered to stand - no no
you can do that's what keeps people in
Hollywood you're like you don't even
think should I give this up because I
had it once you know I'm afraid to be
sauce to be so new like fitness were the
second time to not think about doing the
bit they're worth I thought that was
cheating dog I can't say that because
that worked last time
nobody told me oh yeah yeah he did a bit
of waiting for be like ah - now like the
hell did you think that a great set
movie off at least what I thought was
that I'm a comedian yeah I missed my
calling this is a why did I play
football
why did I go to college I could have
saved that money coulda came straight to
the improv it's so mean it's so many bit
from like the Mike Epps to the Nick
Cannon's to a whole bunch of people who
just went straight bo burnham they just
went straight to the stage you know what
I mean as kids and now these people are
multimillionaires and I'm like Here I am
I'm the only [ __ ] comedian with a
hundred and twenty thousand and student
loans money and went straight to the
stage and then but it made me better I'm
glad I went to UM I'm glad I
got to education I speak differently I
talk differently I think differently
I learned to appeal to a diverse group
of people you know and that [ __ ] helped
me earlier a fraternity Curtin has
connections right College is helpful for
right right but you know this stand-up
game it's just all about funny and
opportunity in the right place at the
right time it ain't about being the
funniest know anything about being the
best in the game
it's about impressing the right people
at the right time and you got the right
set so how did it have that oh [ __ ]
moments how did your SNL like audition
and all that stuff go down how did that
how did you get it how many times had
you done I auditioned now in that one
sitting for like three it was like three
times we auditioned three times three
different seasons it's him okay yeah so
uh yeah and it was 2003 they was looking
for the new black Tracy Morgan right
yeah and they was looking for the new
black guy that's what every body heard
from New York shot town Miami Atlanta LA
were they still looking you think for an
Eddie Murphy like guy who to blow up to
that level
Garrett Morris well that was what
what's-his-face said that Chris Rock
yeah I think was Chris Rock has said
that he was there was so much pressure
for him to be the next day the ghost of
Eddie Murphy yeah you know what I wasn't
us
I wasn't an SNL fan you know I must
admit I was uh I was living color's yeah
I watched in living color
I watched death of Jimmy Jam you know I
watched comic view you know him when I
was a kid I watched Eddie Murphy be on
Saturday Night Live do James Brown do
Gumby do buckwheat you know mr.
Robinson's name was on the casual use
party
when I started it was Tina Fey and Jimmy
Fallon Darrell Hammond horatio sanz you
remind me a tiny bit of a ratio but you
like a ratio on steroids you like
Horatio and John Belushi had asked you
he don't got all skinny now yeah he's
different Kenan Thompson who still there
he's throwing over there yes we came in
together right oh right yes yeah no he's
been on 15 years you know yeah yeah we
got there no three before that I think
it was like Tim Meadows and Kevin Nealon
had been like the longest-running
I was now him Oh Daryl Hannah okay and
Kenan just wow that's good yeah they
need a special special they need to get
a statue saying like the Hall of Fame
see you know did you get it started as a
not-ready-for-prime-time player or were
you a featured a feature that you do
feature for two years and then a third
year to make me a cast member and then
after my third year they were like yeah
I auditioned that stand up New York in
New York all the comics I was in group
see I was I was living in Group C motel
man it was that it had to be at least 60
dudes really the 60 black dude almost
trying to do it they gave you seven
minutes oh my god I don't know 45
minutes - what - am i read that uh
Janeane Garofalo that's what they said
were 45 minutes yeah I'm Lauren Michaels
did you do a bunch of characters mixed
in with stand-up or what I did my bed to
the characters my bed I had one of the
hottest bits in LA at the time 2003 the
movie Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon had
come out oh yeah so my bit my entire bit
was going through the Magic Johnson
theater on Crenshaw and finding out and
black people finding out that Crouching
Tiger has subtitles because none of them
commercials show subtitles we just
thought we was gonna see a karate movie
I mean
with hot pill popping karate movie I
know brothers just looking at Chinese so
easy so when we found out we had to read
for two and a half I mean damn so that
was the whole thing man and so my whole
bit was just talking about the
experience because I'm in Atlanta it's a
black city
we got ghetto theatres the Crenshaw
Theatre in LA it was people have it was
a birthday party going on singing happy
birthday before the movie and then girls
cheering before the movie light came on
but not because movie started open your
presents no and they won cheering like
we won't the movie we know it was like
this synchronized Crouching Tiger I said
my name is star Keesha Crouching Tiger
Tiger it's my birthday up in here
Crouching Tiger Crouching Tiger hey star
Kisha hey girl called me okay okay I did
that in my whole audition and man I got
the job first thing on Animax me was
like we want to know if you are willing
to do star Kisha as a character I was
like yeah let's do it
we're gonna dress up as a lady yeah
let's do it
there's no problem I want a job me Kenan
Thompson
you know JB smooth they hired JB as a
writer oh yeah he was oh my god dude
that will happen he did a Conan he loved
Conan and he was doing all his his
catchy thing I turned down everybody
there for her
helicopter family I remember he goes he
goes in helicopter fair they are working
helicopters this jar you ready one
alright we are going to work a family so
what are you how do you feel about
people coming down on you because I know
you know black and Latino fans when they
see you dressing up like a woman I'm
sure they have opinions yeah you don't
choose to do saying I want to be the
coolest at what I do you choose to do
saying I want to I want to make people
laugh yeah and that's how you should go
into any job you accept there are things
you say you won't do and you will do you
don't I mean yeah I'm more concerned
with the farther you go in Hollywood and
you get in that room and somebody said
yeah suck my dick and you get this rope
[Laughter]
will you see yes movie bro that was
[ __ ] crazy
it was javier bardem he [ __ ] out his
daughter gets raped by the three guys so
in the movie he grabs one two two guys
kills them right whatever but the other
one and now Javier Bardem with a doctor
like a fancy Soviet doctor so he [ __ ]
so give me the guy he kidnaps him and
puts him in a cage because they killed
his daughter bro
and he starts feeding him out hormonal
pills and little by little bro torturing
him and in the end of them and then told
me he start growing boobs he put he put
it makes this guy get surgery give the
vagina and them and then rape some it's
hardcore something that's harmful got
his pain
our mortgage it is hard revenge a
vengeance that fool lady [ __ ] [ __ ]
he married my daughter I'm gonna make
you a woman and rape you and he did
thank you second skin that's what it was
think about that marry you gonna pay
rapist look at well compare raping but
then you get ribbed - okay I'm gonna be
a woman oh she still with the end he's
do everything a little bamboo face but
I'll take dogs I was supposed to be in
The Longest Yard was huge on me you know
you know and they came out to see my
stand-up and that was on SNL and it was
like as we got it you gotta be cool well
you know they said read your script
which one you want to do like cool so I
read the scripts I want to play the
running back so Nellie had you know yeah
I get I wrote a Nellie
that was like well [ __ ] all right well
what can I do they said well we really
want you to be you know cheerleaders the
cheerleader huh and I was like the
cheerleader
he was like yeah like you know the trans
sexual cheerleaders do that he was like
yeah because you do a star Keisha
character and don't nobody you mad I
mean you kill it finesse so we would
love you to do it in the movie and I'm
like yeah but if I'm doing it like every
other week on SNL I don't want to be my
first movie I'm doing that too then I
saw them be doing right on my name
already for this you saying no can't do
it
and then sure enough Tracy did it and so
when she sorry don't forget Tracy saw me
in New York Club as soon as he saw me do
it voice he put his arm around me was
like Forness let me tell you something
I'd let me tell you why I did the movie
like he are
I didn't even have I didn't but he
anticipated yeah yeah but it once he
talked I realized it was more for him
than it was for me because the flack he
was getting that's the [ __ ] I knew I was
gonna get it's always like he's always
been kind of controversial so he comes
out of that way yeah so yeah so he came
to me and was explaining that like well
let me tell you what I did it was a
winning team we got Sandler you got rock
how could I say no was a winning team
and I'm like yeah but you know you
already got movies yeah you got it I've
got a long career you establish I'm
breaking out that would have been my
first movie like I'm glad you did it
yeah but I just wanna other than that
man then he forgot he put his $50,000
necklace around my neck and he left
wow that was an interesting man I said
no after-party lunch of those no don't
horatio sanz man because everybody says
the parties aren't what they used to be
and back in the day we just thought it
was dope parties but we didn't realize
that the level of those parties would
just fall off so now that we realize we
were at the dope parties and I'm sure
that they weren't um you know as as good
as I don't know back in the day day I'm
sure they had real drugs and real you
know I mean we just had we you know and
if you were doing something other than
good no you know I mean I was I wasn't
popping pills or doing coconut messed up
but um just the fact that the parties
were great
the women were plentiful the celebrities
all came and that you own the show you
were celebrity man I used my powers for
evil every week you had a limo that will
take you around the entire city you had
to turn it in by like at the end of the
night you know I mean it was just like
that's for everyone yeah every every
cast member had their own limo like so
it's like you driving around em over you
even have to go to the park to the
garage you know what I mean you could
just be driving around in the damn limo
with Joe crew and go to different
parties but yeah six o'clock they had to
go back you know how to turn them in so
it was just like down it was just
amazing amazing amazing time
6:00 a.m. the next day Julie's German
stealing like hot chick like a hot
female celebrities acting a fool year
like they're never paid to her act like
that
but I think that's the great thing about
SNL I would never really call somebody
out for partying after they spent all
week with us because it is also known as
a safe zone you know what I mean you
come near you bust ass all week try to
film a live show Saturday night and then
whatever happened that Saturday night
after the show you know that's your
business
you know right it wasn't a lot of what
they call page six which is New York's
TMZ at the time you know it wasn't a lot
of people that pop up in the news doing
something crazy you were no SNL
documentary as Michael Jackson I was
yeah Michael Jackson no that was being
out with you right yeah he was before he
was with Tracy and him and Tracy left he
told satorious about Tracy like in the
writers what'd he say what well he was
just tell him like stories about how
they would run into each and i Tracy
heard that he was doing an impression of
him and he was like you do an impression
of me yes I called Tracy it's all love
you know over here huh which other line
up against the bigger name comedians and
I ain't saying names but the bigger
names they get sensitive like they build
our career after talking about everybody
the more paper you have I think the more
sense
would somebody do it in private yeah
really because they can either go butch
Blasi could either like it ago man this
III lit up Chris D'Elia one time on the
Morning News
and he loved that [ __ ] tweeting me
texting me
he was like finesse that's the funniest
[ __ ] I have ever seen because it's
literally Chris D'Elia talking about his
comedy special that was coming out on
the KTLA morning news and Chris was just
literally like yeah yeah it comes out
Friday I did so when I was there the
next week I was like yeah I'm Chris
D'Elia my special comes out down to the
ground come back up I kept doing that
over know who's like funny and [ __ ] ever
so I like when people have a sense of
humor and you talk about him like that
you know I mean yeah anybody getting too
serious about it I'm like [ __ ] it
actually coming out flip it Felipe
Esparza
I have my first one-hour special coming
out my first my first it was not the
first one I've done the first one has
been they're not coming out bootleg
whatever yes the spirit told me to tell
you Oh
Showtime Friday October 19 yeah man I
thought you know man Glendale what the
[ __ ] why I want to shoot no Cleveland
but uh Brown both wise comedy dynamics
there was like yo man shoot the damn
special here you want a special I'm
giving you a special let's do it
and it turned out dope man only shot 1
did you shoot what - one or two - I shot
one bro you mean to show no he did one
show because there were three in a row
right after Bobcat go we did his yeah it
was like Don freeze Don freezing Bob did
like 10 o'clock but a lot of the
audience from the okay cool and so they
took yours on HBO right HBO we chose
ourselves yeah we paid for that
ourselves and then we sold it to HBO
yeah his wife and manager yet but we the
story
no no he's yeah so he we shot those
special in San Jose at The Improv at end
of 2016 and then it came out in 2017
those dope like I wanted to be in
control of more in control of mine yeah
and I was about to shoot mine and my
agent knew what my manager knew about
shoot my own special [ __ ] that and I'm
about to go to Raleigh North Carolina
what a laugh like it's in church you
know I mean and um and then comedy
dynamics came in distribution all right
[ __ ] it I'll pimp myself out hello we
got Johnny we're here with nothing to
say okay and so full of real toys right
here how you livin yeah and there's a
personation through the crowd favorite
the crowd favorite you Cisco from Jew
Hill I'm just kidding do Tyrese know you
you do impressions you a little bit a
little bit dawg I'm not a big impression
like the whole act is like you know my
stand-up act is just me telling jokes I
don't think I'd do one impression and
personally I think I was like I'm gonna
wait til my next special to drop
impersonations because that you have so
much material you're like let me just
get them jokes and and I was happy with
the one hour like I'm thinking about and
I'm like you know what aim the shame
though but I like
you know it wasn't yeah it's real right
like that's the first the way I felt
with the first one like everybody who
saw it they don't see the things that we
the problems that we saw with it the
flaws that we went through and those
things you know but I that's why I
wanted more control for the next one so
the HBO yeah the HBO and like we made it
they didn't change a thing you know the
one thing they changed on my special was
I do this joke about you know our
reality TV versus like I'm a scripted
guy I tell people that people always say
you got to be compatible
you know spiritually or fine
you know financially or you got to be
compatible mentally or emotionally I'm
like you look you know it's a big one
nobody think about television alee like
you got to be able to watch the same
[ __ ] together else y'all are always in
separate woman's watching [ __ ] and when
it's time to go to bed you don't watch
so much TV
ain't no anthem popping off because
y'all ain't even connected to click on
damn night so I was saying you want sex
at the game of Thrones and she's been
watching reality all damn night but um
so I tell this joking and I said yeah
but I'm a you know I'm a scripted guy
like Game of Thrones I like power was
like yeah you didn't say any Showtime so
so we just feelings yeah so that was
pretty much it but other than that what
I did do though since I knew I was only
shooting one I think I did like an hour
20 okay that's what he did he went
actually you did an hour and then came
back for like ten more two of things
that you hadn't said that you had
forgotten about my special the first one
was the intro yeah they announced him as
Philippe as far as cuz they told us they
were gonna change it and you can change
the poster they didn't it was already
aired we thought oh they were supposed
to change it and they've been
soft food real yam and podcast yeah man
punk
yeah data we have jokes yeah people's
jokes dude
second Wednesday of a second Tuesday of
next month so it's gonna be the 13th of
November November 13 ruber said your
Riverside Tucker take us go dates yes
sure special the special drops this
Friday on Showtime called a spirit told
me to tell you my name is finesse
Mitchell find me I'm on at finesse
Mitchell fi ne SS e mi t CH e ll finally
anything Instagram Twitter Facebook find
me get at me after you see this special
on Showtime if you don't have Showtime
download the app show anything but show
something Showtime anything and then
after that I'm in Denver as a matter of
fact I'm in Denver this weekend that the
special drops so anybody that's probably
I'm at The Improv so y'all come out to
the den for improv this Thursday's no
this Friday through Sunday
come check your boy out live as you
watch the special or DVR it and then the
next week I'm in San Diego at the
American comedy company robbed at the
hotel that causes people abortion clinic
right but I'm very hurt is it yeah we're
outside smoking weed one time there's a
bunch of protesters and will they
protesting we went down there and it was
like our Planned Parenthood Oh people I
know they got a new dispensary next to
that yeah you know what's up what you
got I got a Tommy Nick and Johnny got
Bruce jingles on talk about the Barrow
huh you can't find nobody out this week
man with the template temper improv in
Florida law October 18th 21st Seattle
Washington more theatres October 26
we don't know better legacy 27th Cisco
Wharf your theater November 2nd San
Diego November 3rd
door knob or theater gets other dates at
Philippians Worldcom slash tour and if
you're wondering yes we did pitch a show
to ABC CBS and NBC and they all said no
well they loved it though yeah we kind
of knows yeah because ABC was like no no
NBC said we're not buying any family
shows this year it's about our not
they're not buying any family shows this
year they're going like higher concept
different ideas like the good place and
stuff and then CBS said they're not
buying any family shows because they
have too many and then ABC loved us and
they waited like three days to give us
an answer but they're going with a danny
trejo show with not and not because it's
necessarily and they're Latino they're
both they both have a restaurant
involved don't nobody want to look at
Danny Trejo we found out Friday looks
and FX and TBS and all those places
there's a show called the middle is ABC
but they just did a spin-off and I just
got cast and we just shot the pilot for
the spin-off for the middle and this
right now it's called Susu in the city
but we don't know what is the final name
of it but I that's currently right now
I'm on a DC on a new show that's gonna
pop off in 2019 what's up oh yeah Johnny
what you doing man getting a perm I am
going to Apollo mission convention about
shampoo Dan Laura Bruno
are we gonna go alright who let you for
being us gasps oh yeah I'll keep saying
thank you